The Slow Horses.
Not typical MI5.
What's going on?
Ex-service agent, found dead.
Cause of death?
Heart failure.
Was in his sixties.
Smoked, drank.
Well, I do all that.
Look at me. I'm in my prime.
He left a note on his phone.
Cicada.
Russian sleeper agents
embedded in British society.
They've been reactivated.
More people are going to die.
If you uncovered the
trail that quickly,
It couldn't have been
that well hidden.
Thanks.
Lamb, I do not need the Slow Horses
digging around in the past.
This feels too suspicious.
What does that actually mean?
There's more to it.
Stay back!
There has been an alert.
It's a traitor,
right at the top.
He has unfinished business.
There is a plane
packed with explosives.
Thousands of people,
they're going to die.
Sometimes the only way to
work out why a trap has been set...
is to walk into it.